Donald Trump has been president for
almost 800 days he's been president for
almost 800 days
675 of those included special counsel
Muller's investigation as Molly pointed
out obviously there were stories and
allegations prior to that about this
Russian investigation so no matter how
you look at it this is a consequential
moment for this presidency for this
nation no matter what happens from this
report and it's important to point out
we don't have the details inside we do
know from senior Department of Justice
officials that the special counsel is
not recommending any indictments tied to
this report join us again dana perino
juan williams and chris wallace Chris
well we you know I think that it's a we
don't want to rush to judgment and I
think that because this report has come
out since no one has seen it to say that
somehow this clear is the president
seems like the the the height of rushing
to judgment you know if people talk
about the appointment of the special
counsel the fact is the reason the
special counsel was appointed was
because of the fact that the president
fired James Comey in in the middle of
his investigation if Comey
had been allowed to finish his
investigation there probably wouldn't
have been a special counsel I'm also a
little surprised at this talk about
process crunch process crimes are not
parking tickets process crimes are lying
to federal prosecutors they're lying to
the FBI this is the very basis under
which justice is administered and to the
degree that you commit perjury that that
is a very serious crime and oftentimes
you're committing perjury to hide
important facts that investigators want
to know I think we should also point out
that this special prosecutor or the
special counsel resulted in the
indictment and guilty pleas and serious
convictions of Michael Flynn the former
national security adviser to the
president Paul Manafort the former
campaign chairman for the president for
several months and Michael Cohen
the president's personal lawyer and
fixer you know when you look at this in
a kind of a big-picture way there's no
question the president has been under a
cloud for his entire presidency on the
question of this investigation
suspicions and then a formal
investigation as to whether or not he
colluded with the Russians and whether
he obstructed justice of the fact that
that investigation is over is a big
milestone even if we don't know what the
final conclusion of the special counsel
was you know we'll have to wait and see
and I do think that if and repeat if it
should be that the president is cleared
of the basic fundamental charges of the
special counsel whether it was one
collusion or two obstruction of justice
that that is a major victory for the
president and yes Congress and their six
committees that will continue to
investigate but if he is basically clear
to those charges then it seems to me
that there's going to be relatively
little patience on the part of the
public for continuing investigations and
they'll be seen as simply an effort by
Democrats to try to find ways to cut up
the president after the election but in
the basic charge the cloud that he has
been under if the evidence shows that
it'll be a tremendous victory for the
president and he'll be largely in the
clear in terms of these investigations I
think and to you Dana we're making clear
that this is a consequential moment a
big moment no matter what is in the
report and the caveats are all over the
place when we talk about this but the
politics are front and center well they
are and of course I think that one thing
that might could be very interesting is
because this has been so secretive in
many ways you think about Robert Muller
there have been no leaks no
grandstanding he's kept he's run a very
tight ship and that's a good example for
how to keep integrity of an
investigation and I think that he ends
this with his reputation that was
already stellar he leaves with that
completely intact and now he can go back
to doing it whatever he was trying to do
before he was called back into service
to do this report in addition though
Brett think about all of the people that
have had to hire lawyers
that have had to be interviewed by the
special counsel it is very stressful it
is something that you have to keep very
quiet it's like between you and your
attorney and your family and that's it
but we might start to hear a little bit
more about that I don't know what we'll
learn but we could learn the extent of
it but that is of course we know there
are some people in the White House that
have had to submit to those interviews
and so we might hear a little bit about
how they were treated and however then
that said when you ask about the
politics I think there will be as Chris
said very little patience if Congress
decides that they want to just go ahead
and can just go back over this entire
report you just said it was a two-year
report twelve million dollars or twenty
five million dollars total the American
people yes they want to know what was in
it but are they going to want to watch
leading Democrats on Capitol Hill rehash
this for two years and the Democrats
ought to be thinking about do they want
to show that they can govern do they
want to start having hearings on issues
that matter because you know 2020 it's
really not that far away one thing to
point out before I get to you one and
that is not one person is being indicted
for colluding with Russia or conspiracy
with Russia to affect the election or
his campaign and that's a fact from
officials at the Justice Department
report or no report as we learn whatever
is in it some experts who know this very
well say this there could be a secret
grand jury information known as 6e in
the report that's not supposed to be
released publicly since witnesses did
not have lawyers present in those grand
jury proceedings and it's not
technically a court proceeding there
could be secret intelligence information
in the report the release of which might
damage national security in some way
shape or form
there could be unproven and provocative
statements or claims in the report but
tested by a court process that that are
over the top the Attorney General is not
just a clerk in this process he has
significant constitutional and statutory
role Special Counsel Mulla reports to
him and Attorney General Barr is to
exercise his judgment in this case just
thought I'd add that to the conversation
I think that's an important point you
got to keep in mind here as we hit this
moment in terms of you know the nearly
two year long process that what we've
learned from Robert Muller on the record
if you will what is in public at this
moment is that he has charged 34 people
with crimes breath six of six people who
were intimate with President Trump you
know Mike Flynn for example Paul
Manafort apparently manna port was
providing polling information like all
of this is known because of the
indictments that were filed by robert
muller in addition you have 24 people of
the 34 in total that have been charged
with crime who are Russians who in fact
are Russians that he has charged with
interfering in the 2016 election we will
never see those people because they
can't be extradited from Russia to come
and face a trial here in the United
States so that in a sense gives you the
universe that is on the record of what
we know from Muller's work when when it
comes to the politics of it you can
imagine that the Democrats are already
chomping at the bit to say why didn't
Muller go farther specifically in regard
to Trump's relationship with some of the
Russian oligarchs and loans and a like
Deutsche Bank specifically has come to
great attention in recent days you know
loans made alleged lies told in terms of
Trump's wealth much of this laid out by
again another Trump intimate Michael
Cohen when he was brought before
Congress and testified and said that
there were people in the Trump
Organization who knew about these things
that is the kind of line of breadcrumbs
that leads to so much of the activity
that's going to take place in the
Southern District prosecutor's office
here in New York but also give
ammunition to Democrats who are ready it
seems to me readying for the 2020
campaign and saying we want to know more
and we're willing to put more out there
on the record to keep this flame going
as we begin a political process the 2020
election
Chris just to mark this moment Michael
Beschloss historian tweets out and so
March 22nd 2019 turns out to be the date
that will go into the history books
obviously just noting that the report is
in to Juan's point though understanding
that we don't know all that's in the
report but if if the president is
largely cleared of anything in this
report and it comes out that he is using
it to say see I told you so
is there a decision for Democrats to
make on the investigations that they
have launched already as we head into
this next election that as governor
Rendell told us on election night in
midterms you have to decide whether to
legislate legislate legislate or
investigate investigate investigate I
mean you can do the two at the same time
but it gets very hard I mean take for
instance the week that Michael Cohen
testified Congress passed major
legislation that week I forget whether
it was the gun control bill or the
election reform bill but the fact is
that the the Cohen hearing sucked up all
the oxygen and that's all that people
paid attention to I think Democrats are
gonna have to be very very careful about
this because you know we're all tired of
this investigation it's been a strain
piously on the president as Dana points
out especially on people who have had to
hire lawyers and I know what a lawyers
hourly fee is here in DC substantial and
you know but I think the country at
large has been is suffering Muller
fatigue investigation fatigue if the
bottom line and again this is just if
but if the bottom line is that that the
president has basically been cleared of
the major charges obstruction of justice
and collusion I'm not sure there's gonna
be much patience to see a lot more
high-profile hearings I think Democrats
are going to pursue it at least for a
while it certainly energizes their base
they're still going to be a large
percentage of the country that
regardless of what is is is shown here
is going to very much oppose the
President and want to see him brought
down whether an election or an
impeachment but I do think that there is
a danger for Democrats that they
continue to pursue
- lon that it sucks up the oxygen and
even if they are legislating that people
won't be paying attention to that
they'll think these are just the House
Democrats OOP and that's the the chamber
because they control that chamber that
they're just duty-bound and doing
everything they can to carve out the
duly carve off the duly elected
president of the United States I think
that'll be very tricky for them as to
how far they go on that Dana I mean it's
worth pointing out that you had John
Brennan the former CIA director on
another channel predicting just recently
that when the Muller report comes down
that there will be multiple indictments
of people very familiar significant
names quite familiar to the average
Americans going to the top predicting
that this would with all wrap up in a
Russia conspiracy collusion and
indictments from this report and that
even though we don't know the report we
can confirm is not true well though so
he might have egg on his face right and
then of course partisans would say it's
not the first time however you know
there were these that there is a
possibility of sealed indictments that
might mean that there's no more
indictments coming but there were sealed
indictments perhaps those are not going
to go anywhere we just really don't know
- well but if there are if they're
sealed do we know that Bret no we don't
I'm saying there could be you know no
indictments according to the senior DOJ
officials tied to this report on Special
Counsel Muller's Russia investigation
right and so and maybe those sealed
indictments will maybe maybe we will
never know the other thing I think this
report will could take some time for
them to parse out I do think that the
Attorney General will make good on his
claim that this weekend he'll be able to
release something to the people and if
there is pent up demand for it and I
think he'll be able to do that but as
you know Brett it's just not going to be
it's not going to satisfy if you I was
just looking through the 2020 Democratic
candidates all demanding that this
report be released they want it in full
one of the things I'd have to ask them
though is let's say the president is
totally exonerated let's say that molar
finds that yes Russia was trying to
interfere in our election
the Trump campaign wasn't doing anything
like wouldn't that actually be good news
for the country setting aside the
politics they're not gonna necessary in
on this issue anyway politically but
wouldn't that be a great thing if Robert
Muller finishes this thorough
investigation and we find out that there
was no problem there was no collusion I
would think that most people would say
good okay so now how do we get about the
business of preventing Russia from
interfering in the future one final word
here it's just interesting noting the
timing here we're on Friday afternoon
usually Friday late afternoon right
before special report is a time when bad
news is dumped by administration's left
and right heading into the weekend this
Friday is even more so under the radar
because you get the NCAA tournament
playing on other channels as teams are
fighting it out in their brackets what
about the timing of this as we head into
the weekend and is there any you know
thought behind that well I don't think
that Robert Muller is paying too much
attention to that I think the pressure
here the political pressure is so
intense Brett that for the people who
were at the epicenter of this I think
that the effort was to get it done as
quickly as possible that they did not
want this to drag on I mean you go back
to the Clinton Lewinsky affair to go
back to whitewater
you know go back to Watergate and these
things all took much longer than the
almost two-year period that we attach to
the Muller report but I think for Muller
the emphasis was to do it quickly and
maintain credibility I can't emphasize I
think everybody that you've talked to
hear this at this evening has said that
Robert Muller to this point has come out
of this with his integrity intact that
people expect that he will have done a
thorough job and Ben fear and the polls
showed us that the American people think
that he has been fear and the fact that
he has been silent that he hasn't there
have not been leaks out of his office
has helped to assert assert that he has
been conducting a fair investigation not
using the media to his advantage and
that he wanted to get done quickly so
that people wouldn't tire of it
I think that's what it is now I agree
with you about special report yeah I've
seen you have to deal with late Friday
night dumps my friend but I think this
is much more about simply getting us to
the point where you could take some of
the pressure off the president good or
bad leave that up to the partisans to
decide and secondly to say this is what
we've been able to find in a limited but
fair investigation
Dana Chris Juan thank you